first
thing I just want to show this real
quick not this too many
tabs okay so if we go up to
here this is what we've gotten so far
out of the maze environment the best
appears to be 91 92%
couple very odd samples that should not
happen so that's kind of weird but um
the Paro
front currently looks like
this so uh I mean if you just look at
this thing
right you should definitely be able to
do better like this there's a little bit
of a slope here it looks like to me if
you just spend a little bit more running
time you should be able to get something
better I think this is probably just a
hyper Fram optimization failure and we
will be able to get this to be better uh
with better
hypers we're going to look at this real
quick just for some insight in case it
Alters any of what I'm going to do
today uh because I do have a nice plan
for today we got learning rate uh gamma
we can actually see based on this that
it is bounded too low we would like to
have the max gamma be higher so I will
fix that Lambda seems to have this nice
region right here around 95 that is
good update EPO it would like more
update epox but we uh this is kind of
intentional that we don't let it do more
um yep and then these don't get
swept entropy seems like it needs to be
allowed to be even lower which is
interesting though it's hard to say if
it's you know sometimes I think that
these things just push all the way to
one side of the boundary the
other um I don't know maybe this doesn't
need
entropy sweet progress burrito front num
M interestingly yeah it finds the uh
lower number Ms does better but that
should be much
slower and then batch size yeah it's a
reasonable one four mini
batches there you
go Okay so uh what we're going to do
now let's get rid of all of this stuff
don't really need this
paper we are going to start
by making a new
Benchmark uh this thing is we're going
to need this machine
potentially maybe I can run the
experiments on uh a remote box we'll
perfect let me move this as
well so we have a proper stream set up
that I'll be live for a while
here okay
so right now when we do sweep carbs
we've got puffer carbs
here and then we've got our Pam space
samples
here whenever I open YouTube you are
live I stream most of my Dev work and I
work decent hours I actually I didn't
stream I did a couple hours earlier this
morning off stream because I needed to
focus on the math a little
bit
welcome I mean the stream is kind of a
you know watch reinforcement learning
progress happen live and get involved if
you're interested that's the
idea so the goal for today
is uh quality synthetic Benchmark for
hyperr sweep
algorithms um make carbs faster evaluate
it on synthetic Benchmark start applying
these several mathematical optimizations
I've come up with uh this morning and
see if they do
better that is going to be the goal
so what I want to do here is I want to
give it
o1s so let's do
o1 which is what we have okay
score so this is just going to be a
variant of the other task that's very
very
easy your score is just going to be try
to get close to learning
rate and then your cost is just going to
be it's just going to be
this uh and we do need train ARS I
believe
okay so that's our basic
task it is uh
linear and then we're going to do
synthetic percentage task
I know how we're going to do this so
this is going to be synthetic
basic task and it's just going to return
score and cost so there's literally no
reason to go to higher cost
right and then synthetic linear task
linear
cost you get a log
task and then let me think what I do
score times
no what's a good function for this like
sigmoid
by just
over
this so here we have some basic
synthetic
tasks um we will see what we do with
see I'd like to have these on Neptune
but I don't want to sync them like
this let's see if Neptune has a way to
do
run is there a way to just upload a
bunch of
at least until I do uh carb stuff I
think I can start with
ah because I'm maxing total time steps
on every single
optimal and there you go so with a
random search
with
um log
optimal see learning
rate so I'm the screwy
there we
go so now we see that random search
finds
there we go so the total cost to obtain
these results is right
there I think I we're going to want some
better plotting utils this is just
crappy random search here we're just
using this to figure out how we want to
arrange the plots for everything see
it's obnoxious because I'd like to just
stick this all on Neptune but I don't
want to wait for Neptune to run every
go on SI 32 the current best run
is91 now keep in mind that's not 91% of
task solved because the shorter ones
there are more of them because they run
faster um but the max score is
1.0 so we would have to run some
analysis to see what map size on average
it's capable of solving but sweep goes
up now sweep goes
up I also think we're going to massively
improve everything just with better
hypers uh stuff so we're doing hyper
Prim algorithm stuff right
now I think I have well we're going to
see if it works but I think I have a way
better
algorithm just making some basic
synthetic tests right
now well neoc carbs is just going to be
whatever you know version of carbs I end
up
releasing so yes I think I'm going to be
able to improve over what I have
now like neoc carbs is my algorithm
right
guess I've been using this
as oops puffy
point current ideas for improvement uh
some math we will get to
it I have a new a new function that I
think is is going
to it's going to solve the problem of
having score functions on completely
different scales some being percentile
some being like you know log or linear
it's going to solve all that um I think
it's going to solve the problem of not
actually filling in points on the Pito
front uh it's going to solve the problem
of like obsessive filling in of specific
regions um I think it's going to solve
the problem of not really having a way
to consider your your compute budget as
part of the optimization problem uh and
it's going to make it a bit simpler as
well still a very complex algorithm
because you still need the gaussian
processes at least two of them um but I
think it makes it
yeah doing that mostly
today we'll see how much progress I
make I forget if I could get this thing
to render through Docker or
I hate this [ __ ] so much like I just
want to use the base
plotly yeah we're not doing this this is
stupid
oh they just have it hardcoded that
sucks um
why do why does every plotting Library
just suck it's my question
I'd like to use plotly but they did
something stupid
okay hold on maybe I make this
work if it actually
work there we go so I should just be
able to keep refreshing this
score so Yep this is the minimum cost
this is score
okay I don't know the API for this I'm
just going
this I swear all every plotting Library
just
sucks for
and then we'll actually be able to start
doing some stuff
look at how much code this
takes it's like incredibly
stupid this is why I don't ever want to
use uh any of these plotting libraries
these days and I just try to like keep
most of it on uh on Neptune or whatever
because all the plotting libraries suck
you think I want to be using a uh a web
based UI of course not it's just all the
local ones are even worse
verus oh
there turbo 256
fine and I'll tell you what we're doing
why we're doing this in a
second
okay and um
show the
AIS well it goes from Blue to Red so you
can see that this is just all random
right this is a random selection of
do we should be able to swap this test
out
little scaling here is off it's going to
make it hard to see
okay this is really stupid but I'm this
is not clicking for some reason
us there we
go
just have to get this function to be
reasonable and then we'll be able to
start uh showing what this is
for this essentially we're trying to get
a good test for our hyper pram sweep
work
yeah so this is already like zero after
this is like far too
this is also really dumb because it
doesn't take into account the uh it's an
exponential
this is
negative optimal is
this okay so here's the
optimal this line here and then you get
more
points over here
and because the uh the cost for the
sampling here it tries to stick over
here then you get mostly points that are
low cost but yeah this is pretty nice
and dense over here okay this is this is
better
task which should be very simple yep you
can see you always get
um well it's not dependent on cost you
can get it at whatever cost um so this
is just like spread out this
task you can see this front is what
starts to get filled in
here uh though this log cost is
pretty conservative let's
do try this
instead a higher
base yeah there we
go so yeah that's like a nice log curve
right
there and then
percentile yeah so percenti you see it
caps out at
one this one's very close up here
uh but these are important
because you can see that the random
search here it's biased to low time um
it's random with uh normal search ranges
so it doesn't give you coverage
uniformly over cost because that's one
of the search parameters it's why it's
dense over here uh and you're going to
see it doesn't give
you the Paro front up here which is what
you want
it does give you surprisingly pretty
dense coverage of this portion
though
so I want to try carbs on these tasks um
to basically just
see what it
does the one thing that annoys me is
that carbs is kind of
slow so ideally
what are
carbs well other than bread and pasta
and
things carbs is this hyperparameter
tuning algorithm from M view AI that we
are currently trying to improve upon I
think we're going to be able to do so
quite substantially I've got some good
ideas I have some very promising tests
but um in order to really make sure that
this is behaving the way I want I want
some additional synthetic tests to see
that in very constrained settings uh the
algorithm behaves the way that I expect
it to in
theory so you're looking for things
like uniform coverage or like good
coverage of a parito frontier you're uh
like so you're looking for this is a
random algorithm so these points are a
bunch of garbage right but you are going
to want to have like good coverage of
this Frontier here
with the real algorithm uh you're going
to want it to start off running pretty
conservative experiments that don't cost
a lot and then run more expensive ones
later you know you're looking for a lot
of
properties of these algorithms and you
kind of just want to have confidence
that it's behaving sanely uh so that's
what I'm trying to do at the moment
because I've got some math I don't know
if the math is perfect we're going to
figure that out really quickly
the
heck that's the
current current project for my
thank you yeah I figure I'm deving I may
as well stream it I did a couple hours
of math work in the morning that was
just like think about stuff look at
stuff throw stuff in the
Claud that I didn't stream because I
kind of needed to focus on it but I'll
share the results of that
shortly like this stuff I'm doing now is
maybe a little harder to get involved in
right but um the vast majority of what I
do with puffer is open source uh half
the Cod is byy contributors many of whom
came in with zero RL experience so you
know people get to see some of this
stuff done live maybe people want to
jump it and contribute some stuff and
help build you know it's that kind of a
thing and we're going to be getting a
lot more Hardware pretty soon for uh
scaling those efforts which will be
fun I don't know I pretty much just
stream all of my
Dev got to hit those like 60 hour stream
weeks
okay and then I should have my file here
right for
there we
go perfect
so now we can try um we can try carbs on
this
so we're not doing
Neptune it's too damn slow
carbs so this is the problem with carbs
is it's kind of slow because they use
ridiculous numbers of
samples so we'll definitely have to look
at that as
well I imagine that's got to be the slow
Part I can't possibly imagine that
fitting a gaussian process to like 50
points is going to be that slow
what's the general idea behind
carbs uh you're trying it's you're
trying to uncover the Paro front which
is in this case uh you take two
variables one is the score that you're
getting from your RL task the other is
the cost of that experiment which is
usually the time and seconds it takes to
run that experiment and your goal is to
uncover the set of points uh for which
you cannot do both higher score and
faster so it's the set of parito optimal
points in the sense that you can't do
better on both Speed and
Performance so what you get in practice
for this I can show you a real example
of of
this okay so this is the experiment I
have running in this other terminal
that's been going for quite a
while so these are the experim exp you
can see that this this is my version of
carbs it gets better over time and then
the Pito
front is this graph here so for all the
points on this sort of this outer curve
here there aren't any points that are uh
up and to the right which would be
higher score but also faster so you
don't really care about these points
over here these are like bad runs you
want to uncover this Frontier
now whether carbs does a good job of
that or not is a different story that's
why we're working on seeing if we can
make it better but that is the theory of
my current version of
carbs seems to have gotten stuck on uh
the
stuck cuz it found the Optimal
Performance at low cost very
quickly but now it's not running stuff
over
here and why would we want to know that
front because that gives you the optimal
set of those are the optimal set of
hyper parameters in a sense um that
tells you for however much compute you
want to invest in training a specific RL
environment it tells you what parameters
you should use and you want to know the
shape of that front because the shape of
that
front Okay the shape of that front could
be it could be this which means that you
have to like you want to keep investing
compute for quite a while right and that
this is an environment that scales it
could be like this which means that you
really just care about this point right
here and that you don't really do any
better by going over here right so
knowing the shape of this front tells
you a lot but the additional reason for
this is that by estimating this front
what you do is you run a lot of very
lowcost experiments here in this region
that are fast and then you use the
results of these lowcost experiments to
predict what hyper parameters are going
to be good if you invest more compute so
it's actually ends up being a way to
reduce your total expense of tuning
hyper parameters by a
lot several
fold so that's what we're looking at
today like a good a good hyperparameter
tuning algorithm is a severalfold
Improvement to just all of oural
experimentation across the
board in fact I would go so far as to
say that lack of hyperparameter tuning
is the single largest uh scientific
error made in reinforcement
learning just like across all of
research so this stuff's
important so why do it get stuck here is
the question
oh it doesn't I'm s I'm stupid this is
uh the basic test
so here this is what it looks like by
comparison if we do random
search so this is carbs neoc carbs This
Is Random
it there we go it didn't save yeah so
this is your random basic test
you can see that similar to
carbs it does uncover the optimal Point
here uh mostly it gets lucky once but
carbs like locks right onto
it next one we're going to do
[Music]
and then we're going to start trying to
speed it up I think after maybe one
more so that we can do this this quicker
and with more
points cuz this is silly waiting for
this is this so far this looks quite
good right I mean this point out here is
kind of questionable I think this is
well I actually know CU it's blue this
is from the start so this is from one of
the random search points that you
initialize carbs with it's still way far
out there
um and then basically yeah after your
initial random points
it pretty darn quickly just gets
it of course this is the easiest
possible test uh that you can give
I see output and cost going up so
that's probably a good
sign
Oh and it just massively increases
cost
huh that's
weird is it basically gradient descent
on
score um it's not quite
it's kind of I guess sort
of it's kind of a hybrid between that
and an evolutionary search around Pito
optimal points so every Point that's on
the front is a search Locus is a search
center and you explore outward from the
parito points use uh Guided by gaussian
processes that are learned along the way
okay look it messed
up so these points down
here were the initial points so these
are fine and then it does these and this
is fine and then it goes up here which
you can see is not optimal if you draw
this line through this is quite far off
optimal and then it goes all the way
over
here so this is too aggressive and also
like yeah this is too big of a jump and
too aggressive for being
Incorrect and that's probably because of
um the current I have there's a math in
the current version of carbs that I have
that will cause this Behavior so this is
exactly what what I wanted the uh the
random test to reveal uh next thing will
believe I should get baselines before I
start experimenting with stuff it's
worth waiting for the Bas
bye synth test test carbs log Tas there
we
look at this it still does this
um this cost 200 nonsense you
see so I wanted it to be aggressive but
this is too
aggressive 25 experiments in it's
already
jumping to uh
200 all right so you see here this is
too dense and then this is too sparse
so this I I will forgive it for this I
think there should probably at least
have one point
here but I can forgive
that this I can't forgive this right
here these are recent points I can tell
because they're red it's a hot it's a
cold hot map and so these are recent
points for which it just messed up its
parameter somehow which is very hard to
do because um they're not even correla
yeah so this is not a good result right
here so this is going to give us
something to improve
on and uh yeah I think that'll be good
for baselines for now so next thing
we're going to do is let me see if we
can speed this thing up quite a bit
numb candidates for suggestion per dim
right
here it numb candidates for suggestion
for
14 seconds per suggestion okay that's
[ __ ] for
so this is all the time right
here that's obscene
you got 12
offs no
what what is it doing fitting 12 points
it's a fitting a second per Point screw
that
yes so there's literally the only thing
slow in here is fitting the stupid model
and I don't know why that's slow that
should not be
wait
what it's training this with Adam this
has a [ __ ] closed form
solution maybe not with these kernels it
doesn't
Seconds 5 Seconds To Train
I wouldn't be surprised if thisa pointed
Cuda
overhead I mean because how how do you
mess up that badly
instance is
Frozen
see literally five times slower on
GPU and loads 12 parameters onto GPU for
optimization
stupid welcome to the YouTube folks
here so that's
ridiculous uh that still doesn't make it
as fast as I would
somebody please explain to me why they
have to use atom is it because their
kernel doesn't have a close form
solution for
redundant this is the first
time in a
decade that my uh ML Class has come in
handy
finding the best hyper
parameters the
heck well that's
dumb I see
Gan
processes at least this speeds it up a
fair
bit I don't know
why I don't know why like this the thing
just doesn't quit
okay whatever let's do
this that's at least 5x faster than it
was
and then this is what it does for
percentile
ah and this is where we
see yep the other major okay this is
like beautiful beautiful data because
basically every single limitation of
carbs uh that I
predicted has come out in the models
here and in fact
I is it worth even running this for
longer I don't think so I think that
this just shows it so
here let's show first of all let's do
basic let me show this off because this
is It's very rare in science that you
get like a result as clear as this even
with like a toy synthetic task all right
so here's the random search uh synthetic
task here this is where is it random
so here we
go uh the heat map Blue points are early
red points are more recent so it starts
off with some random samples so they're
always going to be garbage no worry
about that but then carbs very quickly
finds the optimal parameters here
there's only one optimal set here um
it's there's only one parameter to tune
cost is not involved at all so you want
the lowest cost version with that one
parameter tuned you can see it takes a
few runs but very
quickly you know within a few runs it
gets up to the optimal here of
one right and then it hovers around this
but like 0 N9 this is a good this is
good either
way okay now we look at linear and then
we start to see it to fall apart
uh so
here it's still just one optimal hyper
parameter but you get linearly better
with higher cost so the more experiment
time you put in you double the
experiment time you double your
score it starts to do okay here these
points are sampled a little bit too
densely for my liking but you know we'll
forgive that um because this is quite a
substantial increase in cost it's you
know doubling experiment time so this is
not not bad but then it just decides
okay I know it boom I'm going to go all
the way to here and it gets it wrong
because it jumped too far uh and the
reason for this is that the current
version of carbs that I have there's a
term in there that rewards you very
heavily for absolute increases in
performance there's no normalization on
this so this is is a 4X increase in
performance it does penalize you for
variance so it penalizes you for
uncertainty in your estimates but this
is just such a big leap in performance
that it does it anyways and then it does
it again even though it really has no
idea what it's doing because this point
should be way way
better so that kind of shows you uh it's
too conservative and then too aggressive
all of a sudden and that is going to be
in the math that is in the math
currently like it is very clear from the
formulation that I have why it does this
it's getting rewarded way too heavily
for uh increasing this number there's no
normalization on on this number there's
a little bit of attempt to make it a
conservative estimate but that's not
log log looks a bit better but kind of
does the same thing these two points in
particular are very recent points so it
kind of gets ahead of itself it doesn't
actually really have a good model yet of
the hyper parameter and it tries to run
these expensive experiments and just
utterly f
what we'd like to see is you know a
smoother filling in of this curve and
then a more gradual extension out to
here as it gets more
confident and then
finally this is uh one of my I think
this is my favorite the percentile
test so this is representing the
situation in which you have an RL task
uh where your score is a percentage so
like maybe it's a win rate so in that
case 999 win rate is way better than 0
N9 right but because I'm using absolute
Improvement in performance here it
doesn't care about that so it doesn't
bother going out here in order to get
999 instead of 99 it just goes right
here so these are all limitations of the
current
algorithm I'm going to be back in 2
minutes I'm going to get a drink and
then I'm going to explain the new
algorithm that I have come up with that
I think is going to do way better and
solve all of these problems we're going
to test it on all these synthetic tasks
and if it doesn't work we will debug and
attempt to figure out why back in 2
minutes I kill this fly get a
okay does puffer lib have support for
planning algorithms like mu so puffer
lib uh is not just like it's not like
most other RL libraries where it's a big
collection of algorithm
implementations it's mostly lower level
Tools in infra so let's put it this way
if you have a implement ation of mu0
where you write one and you use our
environment our vectorization our tools
with that then it'll run about you know
100 a thousand times faster if you were
previously bottlenecked by those things
so puff is just lower level tools and
utilities the main implementation that
we have is just a PO implementation uh
it is very very fast it breaks over a
million steps per second um but yeah you
would have to like Port one port like a
clean RL looking piece of code into our
demo script and then you'd be able to
use
that we're not really interested in
building out a a giant collection of
implementations as much as we are
figuring out like what is the generally
best thing to be doing and then doing
that very well
let me
explain the algorithm
here where is
it my claw window
oops okay so this
was very
long
formula so this is percentile of gpy
minus percentile y nearest over GPC of X
so what's that mean
cars they've got two
terms they have this uh this acquisition
function this expected Improvement term
and then they have
pearch pearch is the easy one pearch
says don't don't go too far away from
hyper parameters that you've currently
explored it doesn't say why or in what
circumstance it just says don't go too
far away from stuff you've already
done and then this term here says this
measures the
Improvement as predicted by your
gaussian process that models hyper
parameters to
score uh
minus your current prediction of the
Optimal
Performance of uh these of hyper
parameters at any cost of this so like
whatever we think these hyper parameters
cost this function is going to give you
the predicted best you can do the parito
optimal point
there the problem here there are a
couple things first of all this is the
difference of two noisy
estimators uh second of all if you
assume that these estimators are both
perfect so you have perfect models of
these then this whole thing collapses
because everything goes to zero and
you're just randomly sampling points
you're not even sampling good points
you're just randomly sampling
points um also this gives you no
incentive to fill in areas of the Paro
front that you think that you've modeled
well you know if you have a model and
your model says oh yeah this regions
about this value uh and your other model
doesn't think that it can improve over
that you're not going to run any
experiments there so you're going to get
gaps in the parito front which you don't
want uh and then
also this here this expectation uh this
expected Improvement is this biases you
towards High uncertainty regions which
then you have to include this term to
unbias
you so basically this whole thing is
fighting itself and then this doesn't
even incorporate the cost of the
experiments at all so then this term
over here they do another thing to try
to bias towards higher cost regions
which isn't even what you want you want
higher performance regions even if they
are higher cost so this whole thing is
like just a mess that's fighting itself
the idea is good explore the pero front
that is the good like that is what you
want um but there are a whole bunch of
things that are fighting here so the
current thing that I have the current
version of what I'm calling neoc carbs
has a few Improv M ments but the key one
is I replace this P search term with uh
GPX minus variance of
GPX a gpy ofx I mean so what that says
is the absolute
performance take a conservative estimate
of the absolute performance of the point
that you're looking at what this does is
this biases you towards higher
performance regions over time uh not
necessarily higher cost regions but
usually higher cost regions regs uh
there are some issues with this though
as we just saw so this does do better
than carbs by a lot but it has some
limitations the key one of
which right here because I'm using
absolute performance you miss stuff like
this percentile right because the
absolute performance is not any bigger
over here really it's just a tiny bit
larger so you miss stuff like this and
then also biasing in the absolute
Direction like that again without taking
into account cost gives you stuff like
the other graph that we looked
at where you just try to go too fast and
you get it
wrong the new formula here what I'm
hoping which I'm hoping should work uh
is quite
different it's going to replace we're
still keeping the galaxian processes at
least two of them but we are going to
replace both of these
terms P search instead this is going to
be divided by GPC of X which is our
prediction of how long the experiment
will take to run and then the first term
here is going to look very similar to
this but not quite we're going to get
rid of the expected Improvement term
which biases us towards un certain uh
uncertainty we don't need
that I don't think at least we'll see
and we're just going to keep this
term except two things uh first we're
going to replace this gine in process
entirely with just the nearest point on
the Paro front there are potentially a
few issues with that but we're going to
try
that and uh immediately if you do that
then you see in the optimal
case in the optimal case you uncover the
whole Paro front because now uh GPX if
you have a perfect function it's just
going to go through and make you know
improvements along the whole parito
front it's not comparing to a
hypothetical of what it thinks that the
best points might be it's actually going
to directly improve uh directly uncover
points on the Pito front
and then the second thing that we're
going to do is apply a percentile
transform uh to these so we're going to
look at know what percent of the points
is the point that we just discovered
better
than and uh the reason for that is that
we want to well we're going to have to
have some sort of transform like this
basically to eliminate the current
problem of
of this happening where you don't look
at these points over here because it's a
very small magnitude difference even if
it's better than all the existing
points so that's what we're going to
have to
do we're going to
start and we're going to do this
incrementally
hang on conservative okay here's your
absolute your acquisition function
here we see I currently have EI value
times absolute conservative
absolute times the success probability
times Max cost
masking these two we will
keep uh these do not come in so success
probability is only when you have runs
failing that's not a problem for us the
Max cost is if you're suggesting
experiments that are too expensive which
again shouldn't be too much of a problem
for us either but but the initial thing
that we need to
do so
gpy of X is
just
model. surate output
we need to do a we need to subtract here
hold
on VP
YX
address now this one is I have to figure
out how to do this one
interactively so I'm just going to set
this like this and I'll put a break
point uh I'm going to have to run this
to figure out how to do this it's uh
some weird distance
metric and then we do
GP
estimate all right and then we we are
going to
go now all I got to do is figure out how
to do wineus real quick and we will have
something to play with
okay argmax isn't going to work for us
here
this well we actually we need these uh
these process estimates up
um is are torch
tensors we'll just do torch. tensor
and it's now it's going to be some
distant Shenanigans here
I don't know why this [ __ ] happens
like breaks your terminal every
right tupple has no attribute
cost Pito it's not Pito groups it's all
parito
observations there we
go so
now
gpyx
shape okay
and we
have
Pito gpy c yeah then we have
burrito
and then we'll
do
cost GPC
x
take R to clost diff this is so that you
cannot select points that are more
expensive than your current
us oh and we actually don't need the OBS
we just need this core
are
currently doing some work on carbs
blender do I
have hang on let me go find
him do I have the 3D model on here or do
I have to go find it from uh from
somewhere else
yeah that's annoying I might have to go
find the old object file I'm sure I have
it I might have to go find it
that would be pretty funny but don't eat
the
puffer don't catch the puffer
oh
pngs it's not letting me see the
uh I might have to get it off
my pc there should be the op file
somewhere though
this is so stupid they're like
censorship or whatever thing has like
flagged all the previous
messages it's just like garbage system
yeah I have it but I think it's on a
different
computer I have to go grab
him we will get you that model though
let me finish my hyper pram
stuff yep
fine okay let's see this let's see what
this
does and uh I shouldn't do percentile
cuz percentile is the only one of these
that doesn't make much
why so this is what carbs linear looks
like more really our older neoc carbs
oh wait that's way
better what
that's way better
holy this is a relatively early
point so I guess this is probably a
random
sample still quite a few down here
but that's like way
better try
50 take a little longer
I'd like to try
this we uh we discovered that this thing
doesn't need to be
tuned so there will match now
what are the odds that we just discover
the god algorithm
this spacing here this is very good
right here this line is very good uh
some of these points down
here should not be
on I wonder if there's actually a
legitimate difference between the number
of
samples it wouldn't surprise
me because when you crank up the number
of
samples you get higher variance we might
have to add a conservative
well that's not going to
pass some dumbass Senator just proposed
20 years in prison for downloading deep
seek
it's actually
better I mean it's
like that's not just a sample difference
right that's
like oh no that's way better look at all
this
stuff it's got one bad point here but
like
this is not bad either these points are
both
certain prefer not to have to run it for
even longer
variance the
estimate where's our reu oh I forgot re
well I don't need R here I only need it
there for y nearest I believe
see so this is a very conservative bound
what we're saying here
right you're taking the variance off of
your
estimate um and then you
are additionally taking the upper bound
really like you're adding the variance
of the cost so you're basically saying
assume that you over predicted how well
this point is going to perform and you
underpredicted the cost which is
reasonable um because as you crank up
more samples this is a sample based
algorithm so you create candidate points
and you score them the more those you
create the more whack your points are
going to get and basically you just get
rewarded for having wacky points um so
something like this needs to be done in
fact these might even need some
variables on them but let me just see
what this does initially
so our currents are
pretty like this is pretty decent
but this like as you add more samples it
seems like it gets worse as you add more
samples it should get
better so here's Leo neoc carbs so this
is what happens with a bunch of
15 yeah so this is uh yeah this it got
to be too conservative
basically it got to be too conservative
because it no longer wants to
do it no longer wants to explore in this
region
didn't even divide by it I just
subtracted the
one we should be able to estimate the
cost function much more accurately so
variance in the cost should tell you you
really don't know what you're doing with
this
prediction that might be a good middle
ground we'll see but I really do think
that there needs to be some sort
of some sort of strategy here
so I mean I guess the problem is just
fundamentally with the gaussian process
right
um it's also not scaled right yet hold
on maybe it just wasn't scaled right
things the
heck I put a break point hello
code oh is it just not been calling my
code why the hell does itak randomly
sample that's
prediction okay so this is your
variance
term take square root of it standard
deviation
does now I have one standard deviation
instead of squared standard
deviation it's potentially more
reasonable
happen any variation I've tried of
conservative in the acquisition function
has not
worked didn't really expect this one
though holy
the Twitter midwit with uh
well GPT is so smart it's smarter than
your Junior Engineers you just have
everything be a GPT rap it's
like funny which your ass is just a bun
to
it SS weird here because this only went
to cost 68 this
gpy
x it's just a
run
oh this
line well that's funny
right let me run that a second that's
actually going to be a funny
ablation use a restroom real quick
that'll run I'll be back in a
second I imagine this will be an amusing
okay let's see what this
is so this
is this is my screwed up
experiment where I forgot why nearest
oh shoot I had that in the whole
time
interesting okay so why would this
happen let me see
happen ah okay this is just an edge
case yeah because it's exactly
200 okay this is just this is not as bad
as it looks this is just just an edge
case hold
on let me think about this
yeah okay this doesn't make sense the
way I have it is why I just screwed up
the math hang on
yeah so what was happening is
um it was Computing y
nearest as uh zero or
whatever and if it computes y nearest is
zero then it's just always going to pick
the highest cost uh point because it's
no longer getting evaluated relative to
a previous point it's just getting
evaluated in absolute scale and that
breaks it so basically there was no
Baseline so just a bug
see what I can produce
next of course these things are going to
take some
tweaking can't just replace hyperr sweep
Al alms immediately without doing a
little
work I put another hour in at the moment
and then I'll probably do uh come back
after
that I do have some other work I'd like
to get done today but maybe I push it
tomorrow we'll
okay
better significantly
happened well we also never had
um the conservative score with
fixed hold
oops maybe it just wasn't working
because we didn't have the uh this set
up correctly though I think that this
will still bias to be far too
holy uh that does not look like it
helped
though be fa all of these are good
numbers but these should not be scoring
high
negative yeah there's probably something
screwy with
that yeah so if this becomes
negative then you you want the biggest
possible
cost I think you got to re
annoying but let's let's see if that
does something dramatically
different to be fair I don't think I've
ever tried that so maybe every single
effort I've had to incorporate a
conservative bound has pushed the uh the
function to be negative which then flips
your incentive towards high cost instead
of away from
it that would make sense
whereas the problem with making it
conservative
is uh you run the risk of just
leaving like all the experiments right
over
here but let's see if it makes um the
high cost experiments more
accurate that's the
question cuz it is still getting
there oh yeah look at that
jump so maybe it's uh it won't be a
problem having this be overly
conservative it even filled in the
middle point
there I don't know if this will be
sufficient though to resolve the
estimate quality
100 I mean the estimate quality is
better spends way too much time so it's
too
conservative also this is kind of too
sparse to really tell you on the
estimate
quality okay let's take the
conservative term out now
I wish this thing ran faster I got it to
run at least like 5x faster than the
original just by taking it off of Cuda
but I don't
know we shall see
the fact that people are saying
grpo is so good is a little bit
concerning because it doesn't look like
a
particularly like reasonable RL
algorithm it seems like something people
should have figured out a long time ago
interesting that these are not
super recent points I kind of want to
change the way I'm printing out
data kind don't want to just print out
then I also
want the um
come with some music
man
nah you may provide your own if you so
like but I don't usually code with
music in fact I very very rarely uh
listen to much music at
code I pretty much will only put
headphones in for like I don't know
running PRS or lifting PRS or stuff like
that
maybe this tells us another
story CU that was
aisal okay I don't like this here hold
on
oh there stupid thing is I don't know
why it didn't show up when I looked for
uh for
stupid stupid
Bots go away
does I kind of do want it in full
Precision I'll just make it wider
I was going to make it trunk
it oh obviously the predictions are yeah
stupid me so that's not
uh yeah that's not going to
work it's got to be on observe
can this work on
csgo uh there is some work on that and
yes generally there is work on RL on
firstperson Shooters does it work out of
the box or anything no it's like a
substantial thing to solve but
let me say observation in param so this
is
score
cost just do like
this okay so we see the acquisition
function going to zero here
is the gum process just a bad model what
the
heck it's like the easiest problem ever
and it's got the predictions completely
wrong
I break something or has it always been
this
bad well the cost model is like
directionally correct at
off how do we solve that RL agents learn
so
slow uh that's not a fair
comparison when you're training a new RL
model you're training it tabula RF it's
a blank slate uh humans have I mean we
have billions of years well yeah I guess
technically billions of years worth of
evolutionary prior built in depending on
where you want to start counting
millions or billions um so of course
it's not going to work as quickly so
there are two things for this one you do
what language models do and you start
training on a whole bunch of tasks with
one model though that gets to be more
expensive not on an industry scale but
like on a smaller research lab scale
um or alternatively what we're doing at
the moment is we're starting with the
important problems where we can just
build fast simulators if I have a
simulator that runs at over a million
steps per second I don't care if it
takes a a bunch of samples because I
have unlimited samples so and then that
lets you do research really really fast
in that area because you know you're
able to run a lot of
experiments uh and then you know you can
discover new methods that will then
allow you to solve the harder problem
problems where things are a little
plans okay so something is just totally
screwy with these models
here let me see if it happens like this
with the uh does it happen like this
with the
original you see it has to right
basic yeah cuz I didn't change the way
we're training the gaussian process at
all
why do models
generalize in RL
specifically well because they're
trained from scratch on one very narrow
task in most of uh most work right they
don't generalize badly when they're
trained on a big distribution of stuff
they actually do pretty darn well
I mean the the analog here right is that
people see a lot of different stuff and
solve a lot of different problems that
allows us to solve a lot of different
problems that aren't quite like the ones
we've seen before same thing with
RL now yeah there you know there may be
algorithmic improvements and
architecture improvements and things
here and there but um I think the
problem is vastly
overstated like RL work Works incredibly
well RL does things that 100 times
larger language models that have had 100
times the capital investment still
cannot
if you change one pixel on breakout is
this if you adversarially change one
pixel to make it break Mr
stream um well neoc carbs work to begin
with right what I'm looking at is I'm
looking at various modifications to see
if I can make it even better and I'm
looking at different synthetic
benchmarks so the success that I had
this morning was very very
clearly uh showing the limitations of
the current method on a variety of
different tasks and now I'm seeing if I
can figure out how to patch up those
holes with that different formulations
of the mostly the acquisition
so far
off how is it that far off
that could be a data transform issue to
be
fair that could totally be a data
transform
issue the model should definitely be
better than
that I mean it's directionally I can see
the cost model is directionally
correct oh wait hold hold on is the
target estimate
different from the circuit
output that might I might have just
picked the wrong thing for the other one
that looks better right
14 and then let me
see oh yeah yeah okay so it's just
that's
fine predicted score Target estimate
let's say this this should give
something at least reason reable within
uh some number of
okay yeah they're directionally correct
now they're just not very accurate
zero why is acquisition function always
zero
figure out why the acquisition function
is always zero that's
insane okay this is zero here yes this
is
so this one's fine because the score
is so this one's fine because the score is predicted lower than y same here but
is predicted lower than y same here but
then this one the predicted
score is higher than
y so it should be GP
YX minus y nearest
oh I'm subtracting in the wrong
space so these scores
here yeah okay I found
it so of course it's bad I'm subtracting
in the wrong space
cost no this is the
um real number
input where's this get appli
param
space OBS to basic space
here they transform the space so I'm not
inang on am I in the wrong space or
not burito
scores no I am in the wrong space
because
GPX yeah yeah
difference and then I wonder if the
costs are in
um are in that space as
well log cost to cost okay no it looks
to me
like log clost to they transform it
back so here the target estimate
surrogate to Target cost estimate is log
cost to cost so they actually they have
this this is good so now we should be
correct now let's see if the model is uh
better it should be it really should not
be that hard to model especially the
cost
so we've got predicted cost and
predicted
score
okay we maintain positive
acquisition which is what we want
to be fair though we haven't applied
normalization to the top term yet so the
uh the cost bias the bottom might be too
much
yeah so this is going to be just a dense
um this is just going to be dense at the
bottom
right wait I hang on neoc carbs linear
Rel
huh did we just do the same test oh yeah
no it's just it's the axis are scaled so
look you get this very nice curve it's
just very conservative as
all
okay and now if we do
so this is equally waiting improvements
along the
front with a linear
okay it actually has it gotten the cost
estimates it's
closer no still hasn't gotten them they
better than before
though again they're directionally
correct at least
I'm surprised though that it's sticking
this close on the
front
huh that's what we
want with only one bad point here the
others don't count CU they're very
early it's very
conservative even without the
conservative term on
I'm suspicious of one thing that might
be kind of
dumb I'm going to try it though real
quick
the reason I'm doing this is in case
they're not normalizing
correctly gussian process the the scale
of this data could mess it up I would
hope that they are but you never
know doesn't look like this is making a
difference so
on
uh no
okay yeah definitely not
it looks to me like the reason that this
doesn't work is because the predictions
suck so we almost can't evaluate the
core
algorithm because the uh the predictions
just
suck yeah this is going to be about the
this is about the same thing as
it's very
weird I'm trying to think if I want to
like load up the
model and I almost don't have to though
I know the model sucks I'm looking at
it
I'm thinking just like save the gaussian
process and see what the heck is wrong
with
thing is the cost prediction should be
very
accurate they both should be it's so
easy and for the score to be that far
off is
observations do we know the
order
steps this thing correct
looks like
it it's really just a question why this
model doesn't
fit when does this not fit nicely
on yeah I got to get some lunch on I'm
going to be back
it's it's just a matter at the moment I
think of the Gan process is not fitting
for some weird reason and I got to
figure out if that's a problem with the
data or it's a normalization problem or
it's a model problem there's something
bizarre here but I'll be back in a bit
got to get some food got to just clear
my mind a bit and uh then I will be back
so in the meantime for
folks um cool hyper parameter stuff
coming soon soon I get all this stuff
working and in the meantime this is all
free and open source at puff. with a ton
of cool
demos you can try all of our
environments right here in
Ocean everything from breakout up to
mini MMOs and more and if you want to
support the project for free just start
the repository really helps us out a
ton and uh if you want to get involved
with Dev you don't need an RL background
just need to be able to write some good
code
can join the Discord this is where we
organize everything we have some
articles and resources in the blog here
and if you want more there's some
additional content you can't find
anywhere else on my ex on the Articles
and I post some stuff there as well so
you can feel free to follow that thank
you and I'll be back in a bit bye